à seulement 12 ans alicia chenal vient
d'être admise au conservatoire à
rayonnement régional de versailles en
classe de danse classique elle danse
depuis seulement deux ans mais la danse
prend déjà une grande place dans sa vie
j'aime beaucoup la danse ça m'aide à
vivre quand je danse j'oublie tous mes
problèmes
une passion que la jeune saint cyrienne
très déterminé et bien décidé à
concrétiser la prochaine étape c'est de
rentrer au conservatoire d'apprendre
beaucoup plus de choses et après
peut-être d'aller dans des tongs et
autres écoles plus plus performantes
le conservatoire exige un grand travail
de rigueur
alicia peut compter sur les conseils de
clarisse sa professeur de danse qui la
suit depuis le début je suis ravi ravi
de sept élèves ravis d'avoir des élèves
plus que motivés chat gagner mais on
aimerait une structure associative
na
on n'a pas les moyens
matériel d'offrir aux élèves des cours
de danse chaque jour et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on
on pousse les élèves qui sont vraiment
très motivé à rentrer dans des
structures qui sont prévus à cet effet
et qui permettent de
conjuguer la vie scolaire et
le conservatoire la formation de danse à
un enseignement que suivra la danseuse
durant son cursus scolaire de la sixième
à la terminale et qui l'emmènera
peut-être un jour à l'opéra
[Musique]